do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight character breakdown video today I
want to talk about one of the characters
that is often overlooked and that is
maester Qyburn as we all know Qyburn has
become the hand to the queen he has been
at Cersei Lannister side for quite some
time yet we still don't know very much
about him
what does Qyburn actually want what are
his secrets does Qyburn have a hidden
agenda concerti Lannister still trusts
him
these are just some of the questions I
see fans often asking about this
character but since Qyburn doesn't have
much of a backstory these questions are
not always easy to answer now before we
get started I do want to thank the
sponsor of today's video this video is
sponsored by Squarespace and whether you
need a domain a website or even an
online store I would highly recommend
that you check out Squarespace now let's
go over some of the things we do know
about Qyburn then I will tell you what I
think his plans may be for the future as
we all know Qyburn is a former may store
the citadel only he was later thrown out
of the Citadel because he did do some
very unethical experiments you see it is
very common for a maester to do
autopsies on dead bodies just like a
coroner would do today but Qyburn
started to take things a step further by
doing experiments on the living saving
well well beyond this man not even a
maester let alone grand maester that's
for the best knows how to save him that
is exactly the sort of arrogance that
had him expelled from the Citadel your
grace his curiosity was deemed this is
something the other masters at the
Citadel could not allow which led to
them taken away chi burns chained and
making him leave old town now Qyburn may
be seen as a disgrace to other maesters
but his unorthodox methods have made him
one of the most knowledgeable healers in
all of Westeros what Qyburn does after
he is kicked out of the Citadel is a bit
of a mystery
we don't really know what he was up to
during that time we are introduced to
Qyburn until the third season of the
show when Robin Talisa find him at
Harrenhal after what appears to be a
slaughter
Qyburn was severely wounded during the
attack but he is able to survive his
injuries this has always made me wonder
how Qyburn actually ended up at
Harrenhal was he secretly trying to
infiltrate the Lannisters camp maybe
this is something we find out next
season well after he recovers from his
injuries he does stay on at Harrenhal to
work for Roose Bolton this is Alki barn
eventually meets Jaime Lannister which
will also eventually lead to him
becoming the hand to the Queen for
Cersei Lannister now as we all know
Qyburn is the one that treats Jaime's
infected arm after his hand was cut off
he also helps escort Jaime back to
King's Landing season four is when we
see Qyburn enter Cersei service since
then he has always appeared to be very
loyal to Cersei ever since they met so
far it seems as if he has been able to
complete any and every task Cersei has
set upon him
so that makes Qyburn a very valuable
asset for the Queen which is most likely
why she made him to hand to the Queen as
of right now it doesn't seem like their
relationship is about to change but we
still don't know if Qyburn has his own
hidden agenda we do know that Khyber now
has access to the spy network Varys used
to operate when he was in King's Landing
you have to wonder if Qyburn is using
Cersei to try to maneuver himself into a
position to complete his own secret
plans because if that's the case then
maybe that's how he ended up in
Harrenhal in the first place it's kind
of hard to guess what Qyburn is true
intentions are because he is usually off
to the side or standing in the back of
the room we hardly ever get any scenes
that are focused entirely on Qyburn we
never get to see him associate with
other characters besides the Lannisters
but I wonder what he is up to when he is
off screen that's the million-dollar
question one thing we do know about
Qyburn is he is extremely effective at
his work he essentially brought gregor
clegane back from the dead and he was
the one that made sure the Wildfire was
in place when Cersei wanted to blow up
the septa bail or he even had the
ballista made that was able to take drug
on out of the sky even if it was only
momentarily
now the interesting thing about him
saving Gregor Clegane is he somehow made
him even stronger and more loyal than he
was before this also leads
to another very interesting question who
does gregor clegane truly serve does he
serve Searcy the queen or does he truly
serve Qyburn the man that saved him from
what looked to be a guaranteed death who
would the mountain actually answer to if
Kaiba and Cersei became enemies does
Qyburn have some kind of magical control
over the mountain that we don't even
know about yet
depending on how things play out next
season we might get this question
answered now I think that Cersei should
consider herself lucky to have Qyburn in
her service I think he is largely
responsible for Cersei being able to
take the Iron Throne for herself now I
guess you can say that she has already
rewarded him by turning him from a
disgraced maester into the hand of the
queen of the Seven Kingdoms that is one
hell of a promotion like I said before
Qyburn was the one that made sure the
septa bail or was sitting on a ticking
time bomb of wildfire and he was the one
that made sure Cersei had a weapon made
that could defend against an attack from
Danny's dragons
those are two very useful weapons I
believe we will see again next season
there is no way that Qyburn only had one
ballista made and I always believed that
there would be more wild fire underneath
King's Landing you told me about
my little birds investigated
and
so just remember something more
Oh magic ah so I do expect to see more
fireworks during the final battle for
the Iron Throne now there is something
else I do want to mention before I
forget in my opinion one of the most
interesting things about the dragon pit
meeting was what Qyburn did during the
white presentation it was very clear
that Qyburn expressed great interest in
these inhuman creatures as you can see
Qyburn did not really appear to be
startled by the white he more so
appeared to be interested in how the
white actually worked we already know
this is a subject that Qyburn takes
interest in after all he might have done
something very similar with gregor
clegane but maybe he's wondering if he
can take things even a step further
Qyburn picked up the white sand to begin
to study it for a few moments until john
grabbed the hand and demonstrated how
the whites could be killed with fire I
do assume that Qyburn was taking mental
notes of everything that was happening I
would say this is Chi burns
bread-and-butter his life's work has
been trying to understand the human
anatomy
now that Qyburn has seen one of the
whites with his own eyes I wonder if he
now has his own plans for the army of
the Dead gregor clegane is somewhat the
living proof that Qyburn has studied
necromancy and now that he knows the
army of the dead is real I wonder if
Qyburn is thinking about making his own
army of the Dead now on the other hand
Qyburn could also be thinking about a
way to stop the army of the dead John
did show him that fire can kill white so
if Qyburn does still have some wildfire
left he might be thinking of a way to
use it to stop the entire army at once
we may not see Qyburn that often in his
show
but we do know he is always busy working
on something behind the scenes he was
the one that was locating all the
wildfire before the set was blown up
annie already had a ballista completed
before we even knew he was looking in
heaven one made when Qyburn saw how
effective the Wildfire was during the
explosion of the set i imagine he
started looking into finding all of it
under the city or even having some more
of it
now wildfire is not the easiest
substance to make however ever since the
dragons were born it has become much
easier to create most likely due to the
Dragons helping magic come back into the
story now you also have to think about
Circe's own reaction when that white
came running straight at her she did
look very scared so I am betting that
she once more wildfire available just in
case the army of the Dead does make it
that far south
not to mention Cersei has probably
already thought about blowing up the
entire city if it looked like Danny or
anyone else was coming close to taking
the Iron Throne away from her now
another thing that I find interesting is
how Qyburn and the knight King both
practice necromancy in a sense Kai burns
knowledge of how the human body works
could become more useful now than ever
before we have already seen the night
King bring several different species
back from the dead it seems obvious that
the night King is using some kind of
ancient magic to be able to do that now
what I want to know is will Qyburn find
a way to be able to tap into the night
king secret of bringing back hundreds or
thousands of people at once so far we
have only seen him do something like
that with the mountain but now that he
has seen a white he might be trying to
find a method to counteract the my Kings
magic well either counteract it or
create an army of his own now that of
course is assuming Qyburn would want to
use his skills for the betterment of
Westeros but when you consider who
Qyburn works for he would most likely
end up using it for something much
darker afterall Qyburn has been dabbling
in the dark arts for quite some time
during an interview the actor who
portrays Qyburn did talk about the scene
where he was holding the white's hand he
goes on to talk about what his actor was
actually thinking about in that moment
and this is what he said that's where
his head is you know the world could end
in five minutes but he is absolutely
focused on I have never seen this before
this is amazing I could really do things
with this I thought that was an
interesting thing to say about the scene
what does Qyburn actually think he can
do now that he has seen a white I am
hoping that we can at least get one more
scene of Khaybar and working in his lab
I really want to see what he's up to
next season I really do think they shown
us Qyburn picking up the white sand for
a reason but the question is what are
his plans for the final battle will he
continue to stay loyal to Cersei all the
way down to the bitter end
or could Qyburn try to get out of the
city when things are big
to look like a total loss there is one
thing you have to remember about Kai
burns very first scene you could say
that he was technically saved by the
Starks since Robin Talisa did find him
and help him get back to good health now
it does seem like highborn only really
cares about having the freedom to be
able to perform his experiments but if
it came down to life or death what he
continued to stand at Cersei side and of
course if Qyburn did try to abandon
Cersei how would the mountain react to
this what he continued to obey Circe's
commands or does Qyburn actually have
control let me know what you think about
all of this what do you think kai Byrnes
endgame truly is before I go I do want
to thank Squarespace for sponsoring
today's video for those of you that
don't know you can use Squarespace to
help build your own website like I said
before there was a time when I used to
think it was very difficult to create
your own website but Squarespace makes
their service very easy to use and
understand they do have an all-in-one
platform that even provides 24/7
customer support if you are thinking
about creating your own website I would
highly recommend that you go to
Squarespace calm for your first free
trial then when you're ready to launch
go to Squarespace calm slash talking
Thrones to save 10% off your first
purchase you can find their link down
below in the description I want to thank
everyone for watching today's video I
really appreciate that and I also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
supporting the channel I hope you all
have a great day
and I hope to see you all come back for
the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
you